it's so nice to be here this is stick
siting this is cool man I'm doing a US
TV show that's cool to give you some
context for where my career is out in
England earlier this year I did a show
in a church like an actual church I
don't mean like an XD consecrated Church
I mean on Friday and Saturday there's
music and comedy and on Sunday it's a
church and it turns out I love
performing in churches which makes sense
on a structural level because ultimately
a church is a building this design for
people to speak in and for other people
to listen to and appreciate that speech
so the sight lines are incredible the
acoustics are phenomenal but also I
think it's nice occasionally for
somebody to speak in a church who looks
more like Jesus than any picture of
Jesus you've ever seen in your entire
lives they Jesus you think where Jesus
was being crucified he thought well at
least they'll remember what race I am
now they won't Jesus you can have blonde
hair and blue eyes before they dragged
you down off that thing poor Jesus he
went up there a Middle Eastern man he
came down looking like the bass player
from an indie rock group in the early
noughties poor Jesus from the king of
kings to a king of leon what a life it's
a pleasure to be here to be doing comedy
in America I'm also really here as a
diplomatic envoy on behalf of the
British population and I would like to
say on behalf of my nation to the people
of America thank you so much for
electing Donald Trump president I
understand it's being received with some
tension in the room but genuinely thank
you so much from the bottom of our
hearts for electing Donald Trump because
when you elected Donald Trump you showed
a commitment to the special relationship
you have stood by our side and not
abandoned us when we needed you the most
because it was brexit then Trump so you
saw us commit geopolitical suicide and
instead of reacting as you should have
done which is to go there but for the
grace of God go we lesson learned you
reacted like this not on your own little
buddy
and now the two of us just going off the
edge of the cliff like Thelma and Louise
at the end of the film don't get me
wrong I'm glad it was brexit first then
Trump it's like the office we came up
with the idea and then you looked at it
and thought what we like the basic
premise can be pumping more money in
some high-profile celebrities because
for a hot minute we were the stupidest
country in the world then you elected
your 45th president both in terms of
chronology and quality and we got beaten
back to a creditable silver medal
position everybody's very angry in this
country every was very angry in my
country and you know there's people who
you should be legitimately angry at like
people should be angry with men let's
face it lads we've had a bad couple of
million years right but at the moment
things feel particularly toxic last year
are going to run tow hijacked a truck
and he drove it into a crowd of people
and he killed 10 of them and injured 15
more and when the police investigated
they found out that his last Facebook
post that day said that he was leaving
to start an insole revolution now in
cells the groups of men who exist in
dark pockets of the internet and are
very angry and they're very angry
because they say they are involuntarily
celibate that's what in sales means
involuntarily so in volunteer
involuntarily involuntarily basically me
between the years 1985 in 2006 and I
know that there are some people here
going hold on were you a 21 year old
virgin and to those people let me just
say this shut up okay just shut up it's
hard for some boys also it happened in
February and I'm an August birthday so
shut up I'm doing a show I don't have
time for your maths right listen we all
go through periods in our life where we
are involuntarily celibate that happens
to all of us but what do we do when that
happens we don't kill people that's
weird
what do we do we handle our business we
go to our rooms and we masturbate to
self-penned Buffy the Vampire Slayer fan
fiction don't judge me
young cool hipster audience you have no
idea I came of age in the year of
dial-up internet you either way it's 45
minutes for a JPEG to load or you
improvise
only two options you have no idea what
it's like now you can stream HD porn
videos on your phone while you're taking
a dump like you all definitely do back
in my day we used have to sit there
waiting for the image smell like this
mmm-hmm having to sustain an erection
for weeks months years at a time all the
while hoping that no one called on the
landline because I be the end of the
whole operation internet was a weird
place there was no Google the best you
could get was an animated paper clip
asking you for your writing a layer
that's the best thing you could get now
here's the thing when this insel stuff
happened I thought well people will be
really angry about this and weirdly
people weren't the New York Times
published articles suggesting we have a
redistribution of sex meanwhile in the
UK a magazine published an article
suggesting the government provide free
sex robots to in cells right now I found
that quite frustrating because okay I am
a nice guy no that was a deafening
silence listen I am a nice guy but even
I have my limits
okay please look at my okay I'm just
gonna say it right every time there is a
terrorist attack of any description
I always think two things the first
thing I'm fine with the second thing I'm
embarrassed by by I want to tell you
about in the interest of building
empathy the first thing I think whenever
there's been a terrorist attack is I
hope everyone is okay fine the second
thing I think whenever there's been a
terrorist attack is oh god please be a
white guy oh god I want it to be a white
guy so badly every time they're about to
announce the name I'm always like come
on grey I'm Johnson
all I want to hear is the suspect is
known to be a fan of Mumford and Sons in
the film lala land that's all I want to
hear because when white people kill
people
no one cares everyone's like ah he was
probably hungry come on maybe he's
internet was being weird let's not make
a big deal out of this and all I'm
saying is there's a cultural imbalance
and I'm just trying to redress it that's
all I'm saying I just think there's a
double standard one way I don't have a
problem with white guys problem with
guys I don't hate white peope
I will have you know that some of my
best friends hate white people and
they're much angrier than me
ladies gentlemen thank you very much
[Applause]